lightenings always fascinated me since
elementary school especially when I
tried to read up on it and discovered
that most of how lightning works is not
understood my name is Greg Lee I'm the
principal engineer for lightning on
demand we're at our warehouse in Oakland
where we do all of the heavy assembly
and things requiring overhead cranes
with the lightning foundry we'll be able
to recreate some of the original
conditions that are believed necessary
in order to initiate lightning up in the
clouds so why not throw it up on
Kickstarter to see what people think
let's get an amazing response we need
348 K to fund the project the scale of
the Lightning foundry is directed
completely by what we expect to find in
terms of where runaway breakdown occurs
so we're going to set up the experiment
to cover a range from 20 to 80 meters
and support up to 200,000 volts per
meter over that length and as a
necessity the Machine needs to be tall
enough to support the voltage which is
12 million volts total and so you need
two towers about 10 stories high if
they're any smaller they would just
simply break down along the surface of
the towers and probably start a fire
lightning is where it initiates is so
far away from the ground it's hard to
get to it's high up in the air and you
never know exactly where it's going to
start there's a high chaotic component
to it if we do manage to trigger a
relativistic runaway breakdown event
it'll be the first time that we've been
able to approach it closely with
instruments and actually try to
determine what's going on and figure out
how lightning gains this unusual ability
to strike over long distances with
relatively low voltage I never thought
we'd even get this far without funding
but we've managed to put an entire shop
together including electronics machining
welding and everything it's just a
matter of time before I find you know
the big transformer I need for free
or ten thousand feet of wires somewhere
in Mexico that's good enough to line the
secondary's with with all of companies
that have failed this stuff is out there
it's just a matter of time to finding it
or finding somebody who thinks it's
worthwhile to pursue this research
you